[Aplausos]
a mediados del siglo pasado una
multinacional prometía llenar las
góndolas de un producto que venía para
revolucionar los mercados pero sobre
todo venía a ofrecer mucho más tiempo
para compartir en familia ese producto
no era ni más ni menos que el café
instantáneo
hasta ese momento preparar café era todo
un folklore
y eso es algo que obvio esta
multinacional no se dio cuenta que vino
a romper con algo cultural
pasaban las semanas y este producto
revolucionario no se vendía este
producto revolucionario que venía a
darnos más tiempo era un fracaso
rápidamente en el café
pero se entendió el problema y a través
de su equipo de marketing inventó uno de
los grandes mitos de la cultura moderna
batir el café
qué pasaba las amas de casa por aquel
entonces eran quienes realizaban las
compras del supermercado y eras eran las
que más se sintieron atacadas porque
este producto revolucionario que venía a
traer mucho más tiempo en realidad les
estaba quitando protagonismo
preparar el café por ese entonces era
realmente
un talento
era morir el café era calentar el agua a
la temperatura adecuada era preparar la
vajilla de la manera más espléndida
posible era preparar los dulces para
crear ese maridaje tan especial para ese
momento café
nescafé destruyó el momento café
a todo esto cuando lees café nota este
gran error y pone en marcha esto de
darle nuevamente el protagonismo a las
amas de casa
son las amas de casa que rápidamente
consumen esta práctica
en el café les dijo darán más batán el
café ellas mismas empezaron a plantear
algunos métodos y algunos decían que hay
que ponerle soda otros le ponen agua
fría otros le ponen un poco más de
azúcar de lo que corresponde hay quienes
luego de batir mucho y llegar a un color
muy muy claro
lo ponen en la era
muchos métodos quien de ustedes no abate
el café
quien de ustedes no ha hecho una
competencia con sus parejas con sus
amistades a erc y un bate más el café
quien le saca más espuma al café
bueno no vengo acá a hablar de nescafé
me di café instantáneo vengo a hablar de
estos inventos estas tecnologías que
llegan que están con nosotros y vienen a
mejorar nuestras vidas entre comillas
vienen a ofrecernos principalmente mucho
más tiempo para nosotros para nuestras
familias vienen a ofrecernos una manera
de vivir más fácil
si hablamos de más fácil si hablamos de
más tiempo hablamos de confort
tenemos que hacer una la primera
pregunta
porque a eso vine acá a cuestionar
estamos preparados para disfrutar
sabemos disfrutar
o disfrutar para nosotros es un estado
de inercia
porque estamos empujados culturalmente a
disfrutar
ustedes saben disfrutar
estas tecnologías que hoy en día habitan
con nosotros y están constantemente
transversales a nuestra forma de vida ya
están con nosotros hace hace mucho
tiempo que están con nosotros
una de ellas es por ejemplo el internet
de las cosas no voy a hablar de que es
el internet las cosas sólo voy a traerlo
como motor de lo que les estoy hablando
y le voy a poner tres ejemplos
el primero
imaginen sensores en las calles en
aquella zona donde es muy complicado
conseguir un lugar para estacionar el
auto
imaginen esos sensores conectados
directamente con nuestra aplicación en
un teléfono móvil en donde nos está
diciendo qué lugar está disponible
cuál es el trayecto más adecuado qué
tengo que hacer para ese lugar y así
tirándome opciones a b c d con el solo
objeto de ordenar mi viaje y optimizar
el tiempo
cuánto tiempo perdieron ustedes buscando
un lugar para estacionar acá
sacan la cuenta de cuánto tiempo pierden
buscando un lugar para estacionar el
auto
está comprobado esta tecnología estos
sensores esta aplicación la vienen
usando en varios pueblos de europa que
tienen este problema fundamental y la
gente al mes gana entre 35 y 45 minutos
usando esta aplicación
si yo a ustedes les doy de ahora en más
45 minutos por mes que harían con esos
45 minutos
están listos para usar el tiempo de una
manera distinta
porque créanme que esta tecnología
tiene muchas cosas buenas muchas cosas
malas pero si algo indiscutible
que viene a traer es más tiempo para
nosotros otra forma de vivir otra forma
de tener placer
otra forma de usar también
y hablando de gozar imagínense cuántas
veces ustedes han entrado a una sala de
cine y la temperatura no era la que
ustedes esperaban o se suben a un micro
de larga distancia y no pueden creer el
frío que hace ahí arriba
imaginen una aplicación conectada con el
sistema de climatización en donde cada
uno de ustedes que entra acá
el sistema toma la temperatura que
habitualmente habitan regulan a donde
trabajan donde viven y promedia la
climatización del lugar
seguramente la experiencia del usuario
sería mucho mejor
y el tercer ejemplo
tiene más que ver con el confort el
tiempo que lo vinculamos al confort al
goce y mejía en un sensor adentro de
nuestro cuerpo que constantemente está
enviando información de todo lo que nos
pasa información médica clave necesaria
para que nuestro médico de cabecera de
su dispositivo móvil puedan leerlo en
tiempo real
imagínense nunca más ir a una sala de
espera
cuánto tiempo ganaría
si nunca más van a una sala de espera
que vamos a ganar tiempo con toda esta
tecnología y que realmente lo estamos
ganando es indiscutible
el tema es que vamos a hacer con ese
tiempo
muchas veces veo a mi alrededor gente
que le cancela en una reunión de 45
minutos
y automáticamente como por inercia
cultural siguen trabajando en otra cosa
creo que al 90% de ustedes seguramente
le pasa eso
si a ustedes imaginen mañana lunes 10 30
de la mañana
les cancela en una reunión o no les
llega un paciente al consultorio o pase
lo que pase tienen 45 minutos libres que
no esperaban tener
que van a ser
saben usar su tiempo libre
saben gozar de repente en un tiempo
libre que aparece
porque ahí parece que el goce hoy en día
tiene agenda
y el goce no debería tener agenda
parece que solamente estamos permitidos
para disfrutar los fines de semana los
feriados los encuentros con amistades
los viajes pero no estamos dispuestos a
disfrutar con el tiempo libre que
empieza a aparecer en nuestras vidas
toda esta tecnología esta tecnología el
internet de las cosas la inteligencia
artificial
viene a resolver muchas cuestiones que
los humanos haciendo labores vienen a
quitarnos puestos de trabajo es verdad
es otra discusión es otra charla también
hay soluciones parece para ese problema
pero lo que quiero hablar es qué vamos a
hacer con el tiempo que ganamos
a raíz de lo que esta tecnología nos
generan
y voy a poner el caso inverso
fíjense cómo funciona este sistema que a
veces parece que la tecnología está
gozando en nosotros
seguramente muchos de ustedes conocen el
término de game if y cage john
dignificación es un concepto que se usa
en muchos campos hoy en día pero
principalmente en el marketing y en la
publicidad lo que hace es tomar el poder
lúdico de la industria de los
videojuegos
utilizar el goce del aplauso en función
de la acción
y encaminarlo hacernos sentir bien para
comprar o tener una gran experiencia de
usuario vinculada al marketing al
comercio
o acaso estos sitios de compra online no
nos están midiendo todo el tiempo en
niveles o acaso cada vez que damos like
o acaso cada vez que compramos algo
tintín quien clinton el indicador de
nuestro nivel va subiendo y parece que
va a estallar y a medida que subimos de
nivel como en un videojuego tenemos
beneficios nos sentimos importantes
la tecnología está jugando con nuestro
goce
voy a proponerles una acción
quiero que cierren los ojos
cierren los ojos
quiero que imaginen en sus manos un sois
tico una palanca de videojuegos
quiero que imaginen frente a ustedes
un televisor con una escena de un
videojuego en donde hay dos caminos y
nuestro
personaje principal quienes estamos
controlando tiene que elegir un camino
parece ser ha faltado gris el otro
parece ser verde y tiene tierra
en el gris parece haber una ciudad al
final con luces prendidas
la tierra parece haber algo de agua y no
sabemos bien a dónde nos lleva
uno parece natural el otro parece tener
la mano del hombre uno parece ser más
rápido el otro puede ser más disfrutable
uno parece ser más sano y el otro parece
ser un poco más demandante
entonces la pregunta es
ustedes
battle el café
gracias
[Aplausos]